jay uh where'd you grow up where you're
from originally
originally um ohio cincinnati
i was born and then ended up in indiana
in 2008 i ended up here in skid row
why'd you come out here to skid row
um because there wasn't no resources
where i came from
um i ran out of resources uh the economy
was low
and so i found
this place on the internet actually and
came out here
with my tax returns tell me about your
childhood you had
both your parents growing up as a kid
yeah um
it was typical you know family you know
i was well taken care of until about my
teenage years about 14 i moved out
and it was um up and down
how would you describe your childhood um
uh family-wise i was well taken care of
but um
growing up um socially it was i was very
um
backward um i had a speech impediment
a learning disability um also
just being who the kind person that i am
they uh i was always um you know
pushed aside or zeroed out
was there a certain point where you
became
transgender or do you think you've
always been this way
well yeah since i can remember
kindergarten
right so you always knew this was your
orientation
yeah kindergarten i got my first kiss on
the leg
and butterflies um it's been all
downhill since
it's been downhill yeah jokingly but
yeah in your life out here when i met
you
you were you were living on the street
right yeah when i met you about seven
eight years ago you were living on the
street
yeah i was there for seven years i met
somebody
um he started running a resource center
nonprofit and i started it with him
um you have housing now you're you're in
an apartment on skid row
i got it 2013. has been
quite horrid um
i guess we don't realize it but like we
become accustomed to some things and
um ever since i got the housing it's
been hard because i got so
adjusted to the outside and all the
activity around me
but um so
let's make the adjustment a little
harder it's interesting
so there's an adjustment from to go from
living on the street to living in an
apartment
yeah i thought it would be awesome but
it's been rough
what was hard about that transition um
being alone
um just like spiritually i've been going
through a lot of things
and um yeah the street life is very
social yeah there's people
all over the streets all the time and
you're always
there's always some kind you're always
looking around you know
there's always something stimulating but
um
once you get inside and close the doors
and you're all alone it's
like everything closes in on you
you kind of learned i had to learn to
deal with yourself a little more
and how do you support yourself um
or how have you supported yourself over
the years
um when i first met you i think you were
dating guys right
yeah um do you still do that
what was that you still do that yeah
dating yeah um no i don't anymore i'm on
disability
for my mental um what's your mental
condition
um i have uh psychosis and
uh depression anorexia
trans gender dysphoria for some reason
they consider that a disability i don't
but um
i got ssdi in 2013 which has been a
big blessing because you can't depend on
nobody out here
um you gotta find a hustle yourself
and me coming from a small town it was a
big
culture shock um
because everything's so busy and it's so
fast and
i'm just standing there
dumbfounded on everything
have you had bad things happen to you
here um
being transgender do you get picked out
um yes
a lot um but
the whole overall majority is very more
um you know just well
welcoming of it it's more accepted here
right yeah
than it would be yeah indiana exactly
are you different um i was in shock i
mean people don't even blink an eye and
just call you she and that's
a big shock from where i'm from um
you have to pry their teeth out let them
know
look this ain't cool but um
you still have to watch your back out
here there's you know a lot of
um deceiving people um
which is scary because i had to learn
the hard way
how deceiving people can be i'm not
saying they're bad people
but you know there's a survival program
around
out here um
you just got to learn to respect
everybody and
keep on your side of the road and keep
pushing
and usually it's pretty cool what's been
the most important lesson you learned
since you came out to california
improvising and even though sometimes
people don't act like
the community is important
because as a whole is what makes us get
real
but a lot of times we push through every
day just trying to make it
and not realizing that but
when it comes down to it there's usually
somebody you can depend on
to get through something and do you have
friends
um yeah a few in my housing
[Music]
um
like i said it's been a big adjustment
i have i think i have a big trust issue
with a lot of people so
[Music]
my mind wants to be you want to be you
know live in this
fantasy life but your mind keeps telling
you something different
um it's kind of hard you still have
contact with your family
um somewhat i haven't been lately
but i was the majority of the time i've
been down here
how was your relationship with them were
your parents accepting of you
they tried but it was hard for him
as part of the reason why i came down
here um
but i had to learn that it's not all
them
because we're always stuck in our own
feelings
you know um that we don't recognize that
hey these people gave birth to something
and now that person's grown a little bit
and is telling them there's something
different and it's hard for us
we don't realize that because we're
going through it ourselves
so um
they they they're hard they're both
sides of the spectrum one's a biker
hillbilly from kentucky
and the other one's a catholic city girl
um
so surprisingly they
tried but um it's hard for them to
accept because they're so old school
are drugs a part of your life uh
not at the beginning because i was real
bad alcoholic when i came
out here and i was sober but um in the
last two years yes
you started using what um meth
i just kinda out on a limb i just
started using it
and it's just been a pretty bad habit
ever since
what does crystal meth do for you
honestly
it's a social thing because i've always
been so
introverted and kind of hurt it over
that um
another thing about skid row is there's
always
so many sides of us of a whole big
spectrum
a variety of people but the most of us
have an issue that's been
you know pointed out or labeled and um
but that's what's great about skid row
is that it's a variety
and it doesn't matter who you are you
you'll be
you know you you'll fit in some kind of
there's everything here yeah you've got
gang members you've got transgenders
yeah sex workers you've got drug addicts
it's very nice to everything
pedophiles yeah or chilling murderers
yeah you gotta watch all that
that's why like um kind of like a
network
almost people that you know you kind of
have to stick together with that kind of
thing
to let each other in on a heads up and
who's the next new person or
what's been the hardest part of your
life hardest part
yeah um when you're at home with your
family
since you've been on the street i
believe actually
the street has not been as bad as
i say pre-teens and teens it must have
been a hard time
i'm right after her because i wasn't
much aware of being trans of what trans
was
i just knew what i was going through and
so it was hard for me to adjust and grow
in that aspect um until i came out here
and just came out here and it just kind
of just happened just by living it
instead of out constantly pondering or
being what was the best time of your
life best time
coming out here let's get real
um it was the worst situation but the
best
change and best um growth that i've ever
and glimmer of hope that i've ever seen
i guess we all reach for a star but um
some of us don't seem to be able to even
have a hand close to it and the closest
i came to one
is coming out here interesting
what kind of things have you seen since
you've been out here in skid row
oh great i'll give you an example a lot
that's the hardest thing in the world is
i have to turn the other cheek
when you want to stand up or stick up
for somebody
i've seen a a trans
female to male um lesbian
uh be beat up
um and i couldn't do anything about it
um i saw her like months later and she
said it's a good thing you didn't
because i
she's stubborn apparently and she didn't
want to move out of her spot
and she stood up for herself and
like i guess like six eight people
beat her
i've seen tint hoppers
as so they call it 10 uppers um
there's so many things what's a what's a
tent hopper
i'm just a female that obstitate
for supplies or whatever to
um drugs he had drugs
just to have a place to stay or be
cleaned up or
just simple stuff um as
a sands mean because one i'm always here
but too
i can't see going that low i think
um what we have to share with somebody
in that intimate
scene is uh a little bit worth a whole
lot more than that
but um i've seen all kinds of stuff
you know i've seen people stabbed seeing
people
jump off the roof um
i just recently had a friend that um
jumped off
the roof well not the roof the railing
in my building he was a close friend of
mine he was supposed to be there meeting
me actually
and um he died instantly
um some people like their minds
get so full of stuff i think that they
can't take it anymore
i've came really close to it i believe
but
um i just don't have the total guts to
go to 100
um i don't know
what do you think the biggest issue is
for all these people down here would you
say it's drugs would you say it's mental
health would you say
except variety i think a lot come down
here because of the resources
kind of get stuck um
a lot of them freedom and lack of
responsibility and all that
yeah exactly complacent
um a lot of mental illness
i believe and the drugs and
like you said the easy life um a lot
like me
come down here and they find a common
ground for themselves
it's hard to say how that happens or
what i'm talking about but like
when i came out here i didn't have i was
so oppressed you know
by family by my past
and i came out here and i found
a more foundation for myself
you know i came more in line
when people used to say that i had no
awareness of what they meant
but i was i became more in line and
that's
very significant personally to one
person
um it gives you that freedom
majority of the time
where do you see your life going from
here coming from here
i used to say being a star but
um reality is
we don't know how that will work um
when you say be a star and you're hoping
to be an actor um i came out here to
dance
um then i started looking for
extra extra work um
um some kind of gig maybe uh modeling
or um dance or acting
like you said how old are you now
i'm 29. you're what 29.
and you
i think i think i'm old enough to be
your grandfather
what are your goals at this at this
point in your life
um do you have a goal or are you just
trying to survive at this point
that's the problem the last two years
the things i've been through were people
and spiritually
i uh my drive is not there
it's a mindset but the drive is kind of
like
depleted and um
actually i've met a new man i was with
one for nine years
but um it didn't work out and he's
i want to say wishy-washy but it's not
what she watching
he's like me he's kind of like keeps a
wall up um
but i didn't expect expectations to grow
um but now i do um
i expect something hopefully with him um
we all want to be rich i want to be able
to live
somewhat of a lavish life someday um
because i've never had to
all right jay it's nice seeing you again
thank you for talking with me
good good luck with wherever your life
goes from here thank you
you